it's finally time to talk once again
about my favorite demigod in elden ring
mikala the unalloyed i talked about the
demigod himself in my first elden ring
video check it out if you want to learn
more about him but this time we're gonna
talk less about the demigod and more
about his hailing tree
with a theory on what i think he was
trying to do with it also i know i know
mikala has a lot of cut content that was
discovered but but but
i won't be talking about any of the cut
content in this video just to keep it
consistent i mean since it's cut content
i'm not sure if it'll ever be
implemented or not so for now i won't
get into any of the cut content
so before we get into the crack theory
let's take a tour within the hailing
tree and see what secrets it contains i
promise it will make sense later on or
at least i'll try to make it make sense
now before we can even reach the heilig
tree it is hidden away from the prying
eyes of many behind many trials and
tribulations
the first step to even getting to the
helic tree is to be able to enter the
consecrated snow field which in of
itself is hidden and the only way to get
there is by acquiring two pieces of a
sacred medallion
these medallions are hidden away in an
albanoric village in lyonia which we
won't get into anymore because i covered
that in my last video you can check it
out
but for the second medallion we find it
within castle seoul castle soul also
protects the hailing tree from prying
eyes as you can see you can actually see
the heli tree from the castle
but we'll circle back to what mikhail
has need of castle soul later in the
theory section as it's a pretty
interesting one when we have both halves
of the medallion you can finally enter
the consecrated snow field and even then
the halogen tree is still out of reach
in order to even enter the vicinity of
the heli tree you have to pass through a
perpetual blizzard with only lights
guiding the way and the town of ordina
within the town you have to complete the
trial of the evergel interestingly
within the evergl you'll find some black
knife assassins you'd even find a corpse
of a black knife assassin within ordina
now i don't think the black knife
assassins are here defending the hailing
tree rather they're definitely trapped
within the evergell but that's open to
speculations
a simple chart like this is no match for
our wit
we simply have to light the statues of
mykola in order to pass the trial and
upon successfully completing the trial
we can finally enter the domain of the
hailing tree
first thing i want to talk about here
are the envoys from my last video i got
questions regarding if these are
albenorics my answer is no they're not
weirdly enough i'm not sure what they
are but based on their item drops and
the item descriptions that talk about
them
they are some sort of bloodless monster
that appears when there is an arrival of
a new god
whether they're here for mykola or
melania is unknown but i'm 100 sure they
aren't albinorics at least that's what
we get from the item descriptions that
talk about them
in any case back to the hailing tree as
we can see it isn't doing so well
it's slowly being taken over by the
scarlet rot not only due to melania's
presence but also due to michela's
absence the tree itself looks like it
stopped growing and
instead is withering away slowly i do
believe that the tree itself is pretty
much dead or at least close to dead at
this point this starting area of the
hailing tree as well is devoid of any
hailing tree soldiers knights and clean
rot knights
instead we see them far below in el file
here we find the misbegotten
and ants giant ants i have no doubts
that the misbegotten were welcomed into
the embrace of the helix tree
i mean they perfectly fit the type of
people mikola strived to protect
but it seems like the neglect and maybe
the scarlet rot drove them mad at some
point and
the death and destruction we see here
may have been done by them
unintentionally
which may be the reason why we see them
begging for forgiveness the misbegotten
have this tendency of rebelling as we
saw previously in castlemorn so
they may have also rebelled here due to
hunger at some point as we can see a lot
of them eating the corpses of those not
affected by the scarlet rot but we also
see a lot of them begging for
forgiveness maybe after they stated
their hunger they realize what they have
done
whether mikala will forgive them or not
is something we'll never know we also
find a lot of these rotten husks and
without the protection of mykola this
might have been the previous denizens
who succumbed to the scarlet rot these
ones are littered all throughout this
area
and they aren't being eaten by the
misbegotten probably because well
they're suffering from the scarlet rod
and you don't want that anywhere close
to you now going further we
interestingly find some spirit snails
here who summon crystallines
the spirit snails themselves are a very
interesting addition that we'll come
back to later again in the theory
section
and further beyond this we find very
interesting mages deep within i believe
this mages might have come here with
loretta but what's even more interesting
is that these mages are known as
scholars of jaima conspectus
mages who sought power to quell conflict
their glindstone crowns are also
bestowed by raya lucaria for scholars
whose pursuits were deemed worthy
is that pursuit helping loretta find a
home for the albanorics
or is it assisting mykola with his
hailing tree
maybe even rya lucaria sees nicholas
haley tree as a pursuit to quell
conflict
then again if you look at these mages
closely you'll see that their bracers
cover their arms which seems to be
infused with primeval sorcery if you
equip the battlemage bracers yourself it
doesn't change your arm to have the
azure like crystal
this is true for all jaima mages
throughout the lens between not just
here i've checked the one in kaelin and
the one in altus plateau they all have
this azure
arm now it could be a coincidence or
maybe these kinds of mages learn a
little bit of primeval sorcery which is
a type of sorcery that is based off the
origin of glintstone if we look at the
primeval sorcery from azure for example
it is said to be the origin of
glintstone and if you look at the primal
glimstone from celine primeval sorcery
can be used to
basically transfer one soul into the
primal glintstone and allow you to move
bodies
but again something we'll come back to
in the theory section but you might be
seeing a pattern at this point
beyond this though we face loretta who
may have been tasked with protecting
this area another interesting point here
is the statue at the center which
depicts three people the only people
that come to mind with this would be
melania mikala and queen america perhaps
despite queen america's inability to
help melania with her affliction mykola
still loved his mother now beyond this
point we finally come to el file brace
of the haley tree here we find those
most loyal to the twin prodigies clean
rot knights haley tree
soldiers as well as the children of rot
but before we go further we have to pass
through the prayer room and i asked the
community once again on who this
depiction might be i got a lot of
interesting answers and thank you guys
for that but the answer that stuck most
to me was that a lot of people pointed
out that this might be gauri not the
gallery that we know right now who is in
caled but the gauri that used to be he
called himself a great sage back in his
time and this could be a depiction of
him as someone who understands the
scarlet rot and the cycle of decay and
rebirth
are you guys seeing a pattern now
again something we'll come back to in
the theory section now we also see
images of this in mog's palace and other
places like the lake of rot but if you
have a better answer than gallery please
do let me know in the comments down
below
aside from the mages earlier we finally
see the humans who actually serve mykola
and you'll notice that some of them have
this shining aura within their chest
this aura is their faith to lord mikala
strong enough to burn them away as they
blow themselves up as a way to light the
path for the return of their lord and i
mentioned this previously in my mykola
video but almost all the humans here are
wearing helmets adorned with analog gold
which increases their faith by one which
could be the effect of the bewitching
abilities of mykola
you see a lot of these knights defending
areas from outsiders it makes you think
what exactly are they defending from the
rampage of the misbegotten outside
or another possible interference from
other demigods like moog
or perhaps with the return of the
slumbering melania they tighten security
even further now what's also weird is
that these knights are defending the
heilig tree rather than looking for
mykola it's as if they don't know that
mykola had been taken and i think this
is the case as many of them are simply
waiting and wishing for the return of
their lord i mean even sir gideon
tarnished with approximate knowledge of
everything didn't know mikola was taken
what more lowly soldiers of the haley
tree so they might be thinking that
mikala disappeared but they are unaware
that he was actually kidnapped
but that's just speculation
there are a bunch of stuff here that are
just weird as well at the ground floor
of this area there are multiple
revenants there are crystallines in the
buildings and it is here that we find
america's sorceal
now revenants i don't really know much
about
but they are associated with death and
spirits killing one drops ghost glove
words which is used to strengthen
spirits crystallines are creatures
created from crystals who await the
return of their lord so that more of
them could be created but crystallines
are basically creatures that were carved
out from crystals and given life
beyond this area we'll come to find the
children of rot now this is also an
interesting area as this is already
inside the helic tree itself and there
is a hole that leads directly to the
chamber which houses mikala and melania
was this hole created by moog was it
always here or was it destroyed by
something else or maybe it was even
destroyed by the river of rock that's
falling down
we also find these cocoon-like things
which also envelop mykola when we found
him in mogwin's palace
what's inside of these it's probably
people and these are probably for some
sort of evolution or rebirth
what's also weird was how michela was
stolen by moog
so easily mind you despite all the
security around it doesn't seem like he
was wary of anyone going after him in
the way mog did
but this of course was his biggest
mistake as it may have been his
overconfidence that allowed mog to
easily slip by
how
well moog was an omen the type of people
mikola wished to save i wouldn't be
surprised if he was welcomed into the
haley tree in the first place not to
mention when we first ask about the
unlocated demigods gideon of near
doesn't tell us much about moog
just that the unlocated demigod was
known as the lord of blood did he not
know that it was moog or
was moog just not that much of a factor
that he didn't care
something we're just not too sure about
anyway continuing down here just before
mikala and melania's chamber is a
graveyard
within we see knights who still care for
their loved ones and still watch over
their graves there are also knights that
are grieving for probably recent losses
maybe from the scarlet rod or maybe from
battles before this is quite the odd
place for a graveyard no this is right
next to the chamber where mikala placed
himself which if mikala was your lord is
kind of a weird place to be putting a
graveyard but again we'll come back to
that later
now earlier we talked about the
revenants and the ghost gloveboards that
they were dropping and now we find in
this graveyard
the third ghost glovebird bell bearing
as well as a lot of glove words in this
area this could be something mykola was
trying to learn and experiment on
we also see down here a scarlet flower
and a traveling maiden's clothes next to
it
now we don't know who this is
it could be one of millicent's sisters
it could even be melania's first bloom
like many are speculating or maybe it
was part of something more
so
now let's talk about the crack theory
that i have regarding what mickela was
trying to do with the haley tree
from the hailik3 circuit we know that
mykola was attempting to create a new
earth tree so we have to look at what
the earth tree does in the lands between
well it does a lot of things but i think
the most prominent thing it does
is it takes over the concept of death
now because the rune of death was
removed from the elden ring true death
in the lands between is basically your
soul returning to the earth tree upon
your death and eventually being reborn
by the grace of the earth tree however
there are many that are rejected by the
earth tree such as those who live in
death the albanorics the misbegotten the
omens and of course even the humans
these souls are left forever to wander
the lands between
in a sort of limbo many of them seek
salvation and mikala sought to better
the lives of everyone in the lands
between
now mykola despite his opposition to
outer gods still loves his family and
doesn't really oppose the golden order
so he doesn't do something as crazy as
say
unbounding the rune of death
so what if he attempted to create the
heilig tree
as a new archery
that he could control
one that would allow him to take the
souls of those rejected by the archery
and birth them anew
sounds crazy a little bit but this cycle
of rebirth is something that many have
been trying to do but not many have the
power to do so take granola for instance
her amber egg which was given by ratagon
by the way is able to provide a rebirth
but it always has a defect and after the
rebirth the new life rarely lasts long
they have to be constantly rebirthed in
order for them to maintain
any semblance of life
the deathbed companions can somewhat
achieve a proper rebirth but it requires
a whole lot of time and energy and
they're unable to provide for the many
so instead they can only do so for
nobles and exalted nobles
so my theory is that mykola wanted to do
something for the souls who were
rejected by the earth tree
so he studied life itself
create a new earth tree as the hailing
tree
in order to circumvent the unfair way
the earth tree rebirth's souls
but what if he also wanted to take it
one step further
let's circle back to castle soul here
mikola had given a task for them to
swallow the sun
in order to provide rebirth to a
soulless demigod now many believe that
this spirit is talking about godwin
especially with the mention of comrade
and the last right sword clearly talking
about mykola wanting godwin to die a
true death
but i don't think that's the case i
think this spirit isn't talking about
godwin and quite frankly i think he's
just talking about the walking mausoleum
right outside of castle's soul walking
mausoleums are said to hold the dead
bodies of soulless demigods i think this
was one of nicholas experiments on how
to rebirth souls or
place
souls into new bodies
and if he could rebirth a demigod soul
the normal souls would be far easier we
also find another walking mausoleum
within the consecrated snow fields next
to the apostate derelict which houses
the albinouric philia
who is also meant to give life to new
albinorics coincidence
maybe going back to last writes the
reason why he also wants godwin to die a
true death
might be because he also wants to help
godwin into a new rebirth now going back
to the tree throughout the hailing tree
we find creatures somewhat related to
spirits even if it's just a distant
relation as if he was scouring all the
bits of information possible about
spirits
he might have been studying revenants in
order to learn about strengthening
spirits through glove words and like i
said earlier we even found some of these
glove words in the graveyard could it be
that he was trying to use this in order
to strengthen the spirits of the
deceased in order to prepare them for
rebirth
he studied spirit snails in order to
learn about spirit calling and summoning
back spirits he studied crystallines in
order to gain knowledge about creating
new life and possibly moving souls into
the new life that he created
his study of the scarlet rot might also
not just be to save his sister but also
in order to perfect his experiment
remember the scarlet rot embodies the
cycle of decay
and rebirth
and when we give the unalloyed gold
needle to gauri what did he say about
mykola now let me have a look
well well this is a marvel indeed the
work of a true artisan a meticulous bold
craftsman who grasps the essence of life
a bold craftsman who grasps the essence
of life the scarlet flower we found in
the graveyard could be part of that
experiment too
learning the method of rebirth of the
scarlet rod it might even be mickla's
attempt of what gowrie was trying to do
with millicent but mikala succeeded
earlier basically
so let's summarize his creation of the
needle not only allows no other gods to
mess with his process but also allowed
him to see the true essence of life his
creation of the hailing tree was to
allow rebirth of those rejected by the
earth tree he might have been studying
revenants spirit snails and crystallines
in order to gain knowledge about
strengthening spirits calling spirits
and creating new life
his study of the scarlet rot could be a
way to stop decay and allow rebirth it
appears that he was preparing to create
his own world with his own laws
a world without influence of any outer
god and one where he would provide for
all
now is his intention purely altruistic
probably not let's be honest i mean one
of his powers is to bewitch people after
all that's already a big red flag
but we just don't know enough about
mykola to ascertain his true intentions
melania believed that mikala was the
most fearsome of all the imperians
for while the other demigods squabble
for the power of the elden ring mikala
was plotting not to take over the
position of his mother
but to take over the greater will
the earth tree
and all the outer gods
but that's pretty much it this was a fun
one to make as i said i do love mikola
as a demigod but what do you guys think
do you think there is some truth to my
theory or is it a little out there what
do you guys think mickela was doing with
the haley tree let me know in the
comments down below and if you like this
video please do hit the like button it
really really helps out and if you're
new to the channel please don't forget
to subscribe thanks very much for
watching